bonjour et bienvenue sur diagonale tv
championnat du monde féminin 2016
deuxième partie donc dit fan ou face à
maria musique zouk
on a vu dans la première partie que
l'ukrainienne maria masycheva avait
avait fait une partie nulle finalement
dans une italienne
assez assez terne mais bon pas de faute
particulière on sait que la chinoise wu
et est favorite est donc ici est là les
blancs et on va voir donc
pascal a prévu dans ce match tout de
suite avec donc dans cette deuxième
partie avec les blancs elle démarre
aussi par le coup eux quatre ou cinq
donc a priori réponse similaire pour
mariam ou zouk la réponse symétrique
carlier f3 qu'avait laissé 6 hélas alors
mariano zitouna la première partie avait
joué le coup fous ces quatre on l'avait
dit et d'ailleurs avaient passé du temps
à dire que la la voir la réponse la plus
je dirais la plus commune la plus
standard c'est plutôt de jouer la
fameuse partie espagnole fou en b 5 qui
aurait été bien entendu attendue mais
elle avait donc que la jouer fous ces
quatre on a une italienne avec une
partie nulle assez facile finalement
pour pour la favorite avec les noirs
mais cette fois donc à l'aller blanc que
va-t-elle choisir et regardez on va pas
attendre plus pop et bien voilà ça y est
c'est l'espagnol donc fou b5 larrouy
lopes donc là encore je vous invite de
nouveau à aller voir cette fameuse
conférence
rui lopez et philidor donner un an si
2016 vous l'avez sur la chaîne régionale
tv pour voir l'origine de cette fameuse
partie espagnole que vous connaissez
peut-être techniquement mais est-ce que
vous en connaissez l'histoire c'est
intéressant parce qu'on voit pourquoi
henry lopez avait joué ce coup il
explique la raison et c'est assez
fascinant d'écouter cette explication
avec 400 ans
d'écart alors c'est parti pour les noirs
que choisissent les noirs ici alors
comme on l'a dit aussi hier la réponse
standard de ces dernières années c'est
plutôt de jouer la fameuse parade de
berlin c'est à dire le cavalier g8 vient
en effet 6 c'est ce qu'avait joué
cramique face à kasparov arles en 2000
et depuis beaucoup de joueurs ont adopté
cette cette défense on l'a vu aussi joué
par à nantes face à carsen championnat
du monde
mais l'annoncé à six mois la marianne
zut choisi la variante classique de la
rue lopez à 6 on questionne le fou tout
de suite si les blancs prennent on
reprend du pillon de la dame et en cas
de prise du pion central et bien la dame
noire peut venir en d4 attaquant à la
fois le cavalier et le pion de 4 donc on
récupère le matériel
donc c'est pas une bonne idée pour les
blancs de prendre de donner le fou enfin
ça se joue quand même on peut jouer un
m'essayer d'autres partis en tout cas
les blancs ne prennent pas le pion aux 5
il joue une autre variante tout cas ici
elle choisit x 4 la grande variante
d'eau fischer disait bobby fierté dans
son fameux livre mes soixante meilleur
parti disait de ce coup on trait la
vache
voilà parce qu'en fait il ya beaucoup de
théorie jusqu'à à 20 coups voire plus
qu'à les psys s'attaque le pion central
petit rock on prend 1,4 voilà ça c'est
une première surprise mais nord près de
4 ce qui est une variante tout à fait
jouable mais on voit bien que c'est un
peu dangereux puisqu'on a rockets et on
va amener très vite la tour ans au
centre face au roi donc c'est un gambit
ont fait un grand vide ce sacrifice de
pions tôt dans l'ouverture comme ça
alors les blancs jouent d'abord le coût
des quatre si les noirs prennent et bien
le cavalier ici se retrouve tout seul
sur la colonne donc on va le cloud est
en fête avec la tour et on voit que
c'est quand même extrêmement dangereux
b5
d'abord je tue l'action de ce fou quand
même qu'ils aient attaque le calice et
six four b3 et b5 voilà alors des cinq
ans donc on ne prend pas en d4 on joue
des cinq pour consolider le cavalier a
eu quatre pas de problème prises
maintenant des blancs donc on récupère
le pion et un talent fou 6 on vient
consolider des cinq qui était attaqué
par le fou et la dame
quand même pas oublier les attaques
basiques donc tout ça est logique on n'a
pas besoin de connaître voyez la théorie
des ouvertures mais les grands principes
suffisent alors les grands principes
suffisant général pour retrouver les
bons coups fouet trois en général un
monsieur à briey les exceptions et la
foule fawcett
pourquoi pas tout ça est standard ces
trois voies la c3 alors l'idée de ces 3
elle est double c'est un belge contrôler
un petit peu la casse des quatre on sait
jamais s'il est noir
tôt ou tard veulent jouer des 4 mais
surtout je me permet de pouvoir jouer
mon four b3 en c2 donc en cas d' attaque
du fou par le cavalier seul sans doute
le fou vient ces deux là il retrouve une
belle diagonale puisque sur cette
diagonale il attaquera notamment h7 avec
un petit rock futur des noirs c'est
toujours intéressant et en plus à eux
quatre ils attaquent une attaque d'une
case centrale
il sera très très bien placé petit rock
et maintenant qu'à valider deux ce qu'on
avait dit aussi hier dans cette partie
italienne jouer lentement par maria
zouzou qu on a vu un plan similaire avec
un cahier des deux est sans doute les
blancs après peuvent jouer pour eux un
lecavalier en f1 qui avait mangé trois
ses classiques de ce type de position
voilà puisqu'on a joué ses trois il faut
trouver un autre développement pour le
cavalier dame 17 donc fou ces deux voies
là tout de suite maintenant les blancs
replace leur fou une fois qu'il a fini
son travail
voyez alors on pourrait se dire mais
pourquoi finalement le foot est là bas
il a permis aux blancs drones ward à
gagner de l'espace oui mais à la fois
seguin espace peut aussi être une
faiblesse on va pouvoir jouer à 4 et
affaiblir ses pions à l'el dames c'est
toujours à double tranchant le fait
d'avancer ses pions
c'est à la fois anglais de l'espace mais
ça peut aussi être une cible car elle
est pro d2 est maintenant dans prend
comprendre la dame parce qu'on garde le
cavalier pour garder le pion auxerre on
prend pas du fou puisqu'il est bien ou
trois ans prenant notamment plus on lit
les tours voilà donc là on peut dire que
les blancs ont fini leur développement
les noirs aussi d'ailleurs puisqu'ils
ont doublé ils ont lié leur tour voilà
alors là le le truc après savoir qui est
mieux bombes et les blancs plus d espace
ils ont un pur 5 alors que les noirs
n'ont pas de
depuis on dans le camp dans le camp
blanc ses pions ici sont peut-être un
peu avancé ça peut être une faiblesse et
puis se fout quand même qu'ils tapent
sur h7 ça peut être embêtant
alors fou g4 alors un coup responsable
fort puisque ce cavalier protège 5 qui
lui-même est attaqué par le cavalier
donc c'est quand même délicat que font
les blancs le seul coup un sans doute
ici c'est de jouer ou f4
voilà qui est normal ou en 4 je protège
le 5 mai ça permis au noir de prendre un
f3 et après la prise et bien on a les
fameux ici puis un doublé alors c'est à
double tranchant puisque bon c'est des
plans doublé mais ce pion f3 pourrait
venir plus tard en f4 remplaçant le fou
qui fait que ce fou sera de nouveau
libre qui fusent et f4 f5 avec fou qui
contrôlent la quasi 5 ça peut s'avérer
très dangereux
les noms les blancs aussi pourrait jouer
jouer le roi en h1 et jouer sur la
colonne j'ai pour attaquer le renoir
voilà mais ses pions sont doublés donc
voilà c'est toujours un peu délicat de
les avancer
bon voilà donc tout ça est à double
tranchant tour des huit normales
j'avais une tour vers le centre jeu sur
protège mon pions j'ai peut-être envie
de jouer des quatre pour simplifier
évidemment les noirs ça les arrangerait
d'échanger les dames et d'entrer en
finale où ses pions doublé pour s'avérer
une faiblesse alors attention quand même
aussi au fait que les blancs ont la
fameuse maintenant perdre fou puisque
les noirs inchangé le fou contre le
cavalier et même en finale b ça ça peut
compenser largement un pion doublé
parfois même on dit que la paire de fou
ça peut valoir un point donc attention
aussi un salon faut bien évaluer les
possibilités de rentrer en finale de ce
type de partie tous rêvent d un
alors ça c'est un virus au cou la
torride d1 moi j'aime pas trop de ou
tiffany si tous rêvent d un parce que eh
bien j'aurai envie de plus tôt deux
jours à chiens et tour g1 alors
maintenant que j'ai joué la tournée à la
remettre en juin derrière c'est un peu
délicat mais bon son idée c'est de
mettre la tour 7 tours là au centre et
pas l'autre parce qu'elle veut jouer à 4
et affaiblir ce duo de pions voilà elle
veut pas attaquer contre le roi
directement c'est une autre idée dames 6
et dames trois bons coups logique 1
dames 3 j'empêche les noirs de venir
avec leurs fous en c5 ou lors une belle
diagonale en venant trois voilà je
retarde sa et j'enlève aussi un
vis-à-vis tour dames attention il y
avait la dame devant une tour c'est
toujours un peu délicat
il ya plus de visas vis pas de problème
tour 17
alors à un plan des noirs on veut
peut-être doubler les tours en tout cas
libérés l'actorat fuite qui peut venir
maintenant des 8 ou pourquoi pas en des
huit protéger ses pions je ne sais pas
mais sans doute oui il sans doute en des
huit pour aider à la poussée des quatre
voilà les noirs ont essayé en intérêt à
essayer de faire des échanges au centre
et de deux poussées vers l'est vers une
finale où ses pions doublé là pourrait
s'avérer faible coût g3 alors l'idée de
fous j'ai trois basses libéré ce fameux
seclin f
on en a parlé f4 f5 avec le fou qui
contrôlent la quasi obscène et tout de
suite à une attaque qui peut s'avérer
mortel contre le roi avec un pouce et de
en embuscade
attention attention ça peut aller très
vite donc là ça va expliquer à tous les
coups suivants des noirs peut-être elle
choisit voilà de jouer g6 voilages ou g6
pour contrer tout de suite
l'action de ce fou à la fois en attaque
plus h7 et puis aussi on contrôle la
cazelle 5
bon pourquoi pas alors c'est un coup
défensif alors elle aurait pu jouer un
plan aussi à base de cahiers à 5 cavalli
ces quatre attaques la dame où va la
dame attaque b2 et un cavalier que quand
il sera beaucoup plus actif en c4 qui
plus est ce cavalier pour réattaquer le
pion aux 5
bon choisi pour l'instant de laisser son
client ces six ans peut-être ce cavalier
aussi peuvent venir en défense ils
peuvent venir en des huit bon c'est pas
très actif mais ce peut-être en recettes
après que ce fou est joué mais où il va
se pousser le problème mais si ce soir
il va jouer cavalier set et là on
contrôle f5
une fois de plus bon peut être
intéressant et la carte revoilà c'est
l'heure pour les blancs à quatre on veut
affaiblir ses séduit aussi les noirs
prennent mais ils ont enlevé un pion qui
était vers le centre pour une pure de l
on reprend et puis c'est le pion à six
qui est faible on comprend pas les sur l
orque aller des 8 bon accueil et des
huit c'est pas terrible qu'elle ait des
huit là dans cette position là il est
noir aurait sans doute mieux fait de
jouer le coup b4 ici b4 éviter aux
blancs d'ouvrir en prenant pas ce qu'ils
libèrent leur tour à il en donne une
colonne un jour 1b 4 on empêche cette
ouverture
on va échanger le plombier contre le
principe ce qui peut pas avancer ans et
cathrine millions prise bien sûr et en
caprices des blancs on reprend du
cavalier c'est temps là le coupé 4
semble presque naturel alors peut-être
qu'elle avait peur maintenant qu'on a
joué à quatre ben non je vois pas de
quoi il a peur
b4 salaire ça va vraiment bien loin donc
on peut s'étonner du fait qu'elle n'ait
pas joué et b4 le pouvait aussi jouer
cavalier à 5 les c4 toujours attaquer
pour attaquer la dame puisque car il ya
cinq ans qu'à deux reprises d'abord
caler ses quatre dames et attaquer et
ensuite je prends mes 5 c'était jouable
aussi bien joué le coup passif laquelle
est évident qu'ils semblent pas terrible
un air de la part des noirs pour mariam
ou zouk un coup passif ce cas va les
regarder comme il est quand même mal mal
placé l'un des huit îles et bloque les
tours on ne va pas trop où ils veulent
et alors peut-être qu'il veut aller en
bessette pour permettre fous ces scènes
qui attaquent la dame bon c'est une
possibilité
c'est lent et ça fait rien contre f4 f5
quoi donc c
c'est délicat reprises d'abord prises
maintenant regarder elle a bien fait la
diff and de libérer la colonne a d'abord
donc cette tour de vie active regarder
comparé à la torre fuites qui ont fermé
très simple et maintenant f4 voilà ça y
est c'est leur f4 et là à tout moment
les blancs peuvent jouer f5
regardez en cas de prise on peut même
jouer d'un f4 et comment on défend ème
siècle mais on peut pas on va se prendre
tout [ __ ] en f5 avec un fou qui
devient extrêmement actif qui en plus
cela on gagnerait une qualité un plus on
a lyon une enfilade dam tour
et puis on tape toujours sur h7 ça
devient ça devienne tout de suite là les
noirs sont danger un gros danger donc m6
sans doute le seul coup contre attaquer
sur le pion aux cinq ici essayez de
alors la menace aussi pour l'aider noir
ça pourrait être de jouer cinq peut-être
pour bloquer complètement l'action de ce
fou pas clair tout simplement prend 1,5
f prend f prend et puis ça a l'air
toujours bon pour les blancs et les
noirs sont quand même en difficulté 1
puis on prend m6 dont elle choisit de
prendre alors ait pu aussi jouer des
coups contours à 8 ou peut-être même
tour à celle pour attaquer le pion b5
c'est d'activer ces pièces lampions
progressiste et la dame 3,6 alors à
noter ici qu'un coup comme
dame prend 1,3 pour simplifier c'est pas
bon puisque on ramène un pion vers le
centre et après une prise par exemple
comme tous réussissent tout reprend m6
qui semble qu'ils semblent pas bon mais
regardez on se prend tout de suite eu 4
et le pion ne peut pas prendre puisqu'il
ya un lien clouage qui plus est le fou
va venir en b3 tôt ou tard avec un
clouage sur le roi c'est terrible donc
c'est pas bon donc voyez que c'est pas
bon et changer les dames donc du coup
elle fait d'un point m6 et maintenant
c'est aux blancs de jouer dans me2
pourquoi pas alors l'idée des blancs ici
dans me2 regarder on mais surtout la
quasi ici la couleur des cases on met la
dame / caisse blanche dans me2 attaque
b5 et puis on a cette petite diagonale
qui s'ouvre on peut venir
angers 4 ici et profiter des kasbahs
faibles en attaque la tour on a un petit
contrôle sur la case de 6 alors on
change la en fait la couleur de casse de
la dame
or le coût naturel est joué par les
noirs cc6 et là hop d'alger quatre mois
la dame gk attaque à tour 17 a pas trop
le choix il faut faire quelque chose
tombe et c'est pourquoi pas et
maintenant où une seller f 5 ans très
bon coup très simple fcn le pion g6 et
loué vis-à-vis am tour qui ont v6 et
plus et donc les blancs à tout moment
maintenant peuvent se débarrasser de
leurs pions doublé tout en ayant au roi
noir affaibli il aura plus qu'un pion
devant lui alors que regarder laurent
blanc il a quasiment trois pions parce
que le foot est roi joue le rôle à la
fois d'un gros pions et des fous très
actif c'est pas qu'un gros pions il est
plus bloquée par le pion f4 la paire de
fou joué à plein l'on peut dire que le
jeu est ouvert puisqu'il ya envoyé il ya
belle diagonale pour les fous les blancs
la paire de fou
un roi noir qui commence à être un peu
faible voilà en quelques coups ensuite à
ce qu'on cale et des huit un peu faible
et blanc prennent prennent le dessus 1
clairement alors la food & 6 alors les
noirs comprennent qu'il faut éliminer un
fou un fou des six sans doute pour
contrer le foot est roi
et là hop tout racisme un très joli
alors tour à six bateaux étaient plus
actives en assises quand un puisqu'elle
contrôle maintenant la 6e manger avec un
vis-à-vis dame ça tape sur ses six
salles pour l'instant les cas les des
huit veille mais il est il est
maintenant quasiment obligé de rester
passif presque tout le reste de la
partie
à donges est tombé tout j'essaie très
bons coups des noirs coups défensifs
latéral on vienne devant le roi donc
maintenant les noirs menace de prendre
en chef c'est n'y a plus de clouage
voilà donc il faut prendre angers 6 et
on ne peut pas reprendre de la tour de
la dame puisqu'elle le fou qui veillent
donc puis on prend va être forcé à ne
joue pas d'ajout d'abord fous ces cinq
pardon elle pourrait hélas nord pourrait
reprendre aussi mais tout de suite mais
les noirs choisi ici de jouer pouces et
alors ça c'est un coup aux curieux s qui
s'était pas possible de prendre tout de
suite
angers 6 6 mai mais c'est le problème
il ya déjà des menaces terribles ici
ouais je vois qu'une possibilité
regarder de sacrifices ici en d5
regarder tout reprendre des cinq
attaques le fou et or si les noirs
prennent le fou qui est attaqué alors si
on prend ici
si on prend c'est là l'autre tour qui
attaquent le fouet avec le foot j'ai
trop où on va récupérer la pièce on à la
paire de fouet à une grosse attaque mais
admettons que les noirs jouent le coup
plutôt ici
fou pranger trois escales on reprend de
la dame puisque attention sinon il ya la
batterie attention il ya une batterie
l'un qui attaquent élèves de on reprend
deux lada et les noirs ne peuvent plus
reprendre des scènes du fait qu' à la
prise latéral le fou continue de taper
sur g6 on va pouvoir tout jouer ton gsm
bon c'est l'horreur c'est l'horreur donc
il faut pas envisager ça donc c'est pour
ça que les noirs prennent pas sans doute
tout de suite mais il aurait peut-être
pu éliminer ce fou quand même parce que
fout pranger 3 ici était possible voilà
tout simplement puisque sur d'emprunt
qui est forcé sinon attention il ya des
problèmes de chacun donc d'emprunt et
forcé et maintenant on peut soit
peut-être pris un peu peut-être
prolonger si ou peut-être activer la
dame par exemple ici d'un v6 activer la
dame pour venir à eux deux attaques et
le fou attaquer un peu la tour et on n'a
pas peur d'une prise là puisqu'il y
aurait un clouage attention on perdrait
la dame ainsi on prend ici il suffit de
jouer 3 h 8 et la dame est cloué
attention la dame il ya le roi derrière
et on perdrait la dame se serait une
erreur pour les blancs devront prendre
ici quand on veut finalement donc
évidemment s'ils sont peu quand même
un bond et créer quelques petits pseudo
problème est peut-être on peut arriver à
activer le cavalier par bessette peut
être calé ses cinq as tu as créé la tour
puis après jouer la case 4 je ne sais
pas voilà on peut essayer de respirer un
peu éliminée ce fou mais là un lieu de
quoi le fait le douteux la foux ces
cinq-là fous ces 5
alors bon on comprend l'idée est fou
c'est certain qu'on peut faire [ __ ] en
f2 fou prendre en prend puisqu'il ya la
tour ici et on a gagné un gros pions et
c'est les noirs cette fois qui qui
risquent revenir fortement dans la
partie mais simplement regarder très
simplement up croisé deux il ya plus
d'échec on pourrait jouer quand même
pour isabelle tant pis je prends quand
même et si vous prenez maintenant a pas
d'échec
donc je peux jouer ce que je veux et par
exemple je peux simplement jouer touré
fin et ses plages
le fou est louée sinon ces pertes de la
dame il n'y a pas d'échec intermédiaires
on perd une pièce donc voilà roi g2 tout
simplement il n'y a plus rien plus de
menaces et le problème c'est que ce fou
maintenant reste toujours très fort et
surtout eh bien ils continuent à
protéger f2 et les noirs n'ont pas de
contre attaque alors qu'avec la prise
ici ont forcé quand même les blancs
reprendre la dame est toujours surface
blanche et donc c'est pas la même
puisque là maintenant les noirs
choisissent de prendre g6 et là c'est
l'heure pour la petite variante enfin la
même idée combien de voir quasiment tout
reprend des 5 voilà et blanc avaient
activé leurs tours on l'avait dit avait
une tour en mise à vis tour dames là et
on peut pas reprendre puisque le pion et
cloud et on a gagné un gros pions alors
ce pion est plus qu'important puisqu'il
était au centre et regardez maintenant
cette belle diagonale qui est ouverte
eh oui donc quand on voit là le fou là
des classes blanche on est content
d'éliminer ce pion puisque là le roi
noir est bon on peut dire que la partie
est déjà quasiment foutu c'est foutu
puisque la se fout et devient
trop trop fort on va pouvoir jouer tour
g5 en plus on rajoute de la pression sur
g6 et tracts à 6 et magnifiquement
active le peut venir en 1/8 aussi se
fout g3 qu'on n'a pas pris ben ils
peuvent venir en h4 attaqué la dame et
elle ne risque pas avoir beaucoup
d'occases bon inca l'oeil on voit que
c'est foutu
pas besoin de calculer beaucoup de
variantes pour voir que c'est mort donc
là ici les noirs choisissent voilà tout
reprend un peu fou prend f2 bon alors
voilà faux problème de alors
effectivement il n'ya plus de tours et
fin avec ya plus de tours est fait avec
l'âge et puis les noirs menace de
prendre en g3 est par exemple site d'un
prend garde il ya quand même ici un
regard d imaginer que les blancs la
phase un mauvais coup j'ai pas un coup
comme b4 ça serait quand même une grosse
erreur puisque après fou prend bouffon
gagnent une pièce et si les blancs
reprennent regarder le petit piège quand
même ça serait quand même terrible boom
maths alors ça c'est un beau matin
regardez le roi ici la dame contrôle
tout et le roi ne peut pas venir ni sur
la casse bien sûr de la dame ni sur le
pion et toutes les autres casse donc ce
serait un beau matin bon on est un
championnat du monde
cci fans
cwi fans qui acquit à calais qu'elle est
blanc elle tombe pas dans le piège voilà
fait pas un coup idiot d'un an
elle joue un coût beaucoup plus fort on
en a parlé d'ailleurs évidemment four b3
voilà on avait dit on a pris ce pion
donc tout de suite ces diagonales
deviennent très fort et la menace des
blancs maintenant c'est tous rêvent cinq
échecs du fou autrement dit en échec à
la découverte et je vais bien sûr gagner
à dame
donc là délicat cas valeo 6 alors la
qualif 6 alors rien ça n'a pas remis du
but carrier aussi c'est pas beau parce
que ces cavaliers va être sur la 6e
toujours sur le cloud âge non ce qu'on a
envie de jouer plutôt ses rouages suite
bon ceci dit qu'est ce qui se passe sur
oa suite
tout simplement on jouerait presque
comme dans la partie tour des six tout
simplement on peut pas maintenant je
regarde aussi ce puisqu'on prend avec la
tour je vous rappelle qu'elle fout
qu'ils contrôlent tout regardez ce faux
aussi empêche le roi devenue en g8 c'est
presque mathelin un échec là c'est matt
que fellah que font les noirs là c'est
le problème
alors ici il faut jouer sans doute un
coup comme d'am-dam cette voie là et là
on peut alors qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
il ya une regardez il ya une variante
magnifique maintenant regarder faut pas
oublier se fout là qu'on n'a pas pris
regardez comme il est fort à tout moment
maintenant s'il vient au sein qui cloue
où il fait un échec en 5
le fait qu'on n'ait pas pris ce fut
merveilleux qui complète l'autre fouet
la puissance de la paire de fou à
distance à contrôler toutes les cases au
regard d un magnifique sacrifice autour
des 7 sacrifice de déviation ont dit on
mais c'est un problème puisque les
blancs ne protège qu'une fois et les
noirs attaque deux fois maintenant il
n'y a pas trop le choix faut prendre
puisque adam un pad case sinon on va se
prendre un math par la colonne h je vous
rappelle que le roi ne peut pas venir en
j'évite faudrait d'ordonner la tour en
achète avec protégé par la tour donc il
faut prendre cette tour d'accord et
maintenant regarder échec d'orage cette
force et il ya pas d'autres coups tout
simplement
et maintenant hop c'est l'autre fou rare
dit
voilà y'a rien pour défendre je peux
donner la tour mais sert à rien ça dans
une pièce
y'a plus qu'à donner la dame voilà donne
la dame est maintenant simplement fou
prend échec
roy prend ici
et puis simplement on fait un échec
intermédiaire ici voilà et c'est fini
c'est fini mais en plus on va gagner à
tous réfutent parce que soit on fait
photo af c'est ton prince ont fait
cavaliers f7 mais dans ce cas là on va
perdre le fou donc on perd tout le
matériel c'est terrible c'est quand même
beau c'est quand même beau c'est vrai
que là mais vous voyez comme c'est assez
naturel du moment que les noirs ont
laissé les blancs activer leur pièce à
plein pot coin donc elle joue cavalier 6
mais ça change ça change pas grand chose
puisque là il va jouer voilà tour des
six tours des six est maintenant
regarder ça libère à l'action du fou les
noirs n'ont pas le temps de 2,2 fin une
s'ils peuvent prendre angers 3-1 à lyon
sans doute le faire non ne font pas le
fait pas d'ailleurs en plus alors
maintenant on pourrait quand même joué
fou prendre j'ai trois menaces matt fait
ou quasiment à temps et fin si on fait
d'emprunt yama tu mets la dans ce cas là
simplement on prends en aux six échecs
d'emprunt et forcé sinon par la dame
on va perdre une tour on va faire un
échange arrive si ça va tout perdre
et là on peut faire [ __ ] en échec
roy bouge et simplement on prend le fou
on a une grosse pièce de plus en plus
les pions vont tomber facilement mon
bref c'est foutu voilà donc ya pas trop
le choix on peut pas prendre j'ai trop
on n'a pas le choix donc elle fait
encore un coup la pauvre marié positive
de cette position a poussé senghor c'est
intéressant ça menace quand même matin
là quand même matt le même match qu'on a
vu tout à l'heure un dame fm attention
il faut faire gaffe jusqu'au bout un
mais bon encore une fois c'est unifa
n'en fasse pas de problème
elle le prend avec échec a aussi sa
force échange des dames est là
maintenant après dans prend d'en prendre
simplement on peut faire tous
reprendront menace encore une fois une
découverte mais compter les pièces deux
tours de tours faux fou et il reste
encore un gros fous de plus avec des
pions qui vont tomber partout il ya
aucune chance dans cette position c'est
archi foutu donc c'était ça a été un
massacre expéditif en trente trois 33
coup autant la news d'hier a été a été
rapide autant le guerra il est
extrêmement rapide aussi donc ça fait
peur pour la suite du championnat parce
que là où il fan a montré toute sa
classe et mariam ou zouk à jouer on a
l'impression qu'elle a peur hein ce
match parce que vu la première partie a
parlé hier donc cette première partie il
a quand même l'italienne petit bras pour
les championnats du monde
pour débuter un championnat du monde bon
c'est ça fait c'est pas c'est pas quand
même très ambitieux et vu cette deuxième
partie
je sois qu'elle a fait bomber
apparemment elle comprend pas très bien
cette position en tout cas vis-à-vis de
huy fans n a pas réussi à vraiment jouer
jouer comme il faut alors si on regarde
regarder le classement tout simplement
donc parties nulles et donc elle mène 1
0 donc il ya dix parties dans ce match
et en reste huit mois il va falloir que
marié mozy tous que montre quelque chose
à la troisième parce que là là c'est
quand même très très mal très mal engagé
cette affaire elle est quand même loin
d'être favorite à laurent
100 points un peu plus de 100 points à
la chinoise hé ben oui on sait on sait
bien que sur le papier c'est bien la
chinoise qui est ultra favorite et ça se
confirme dès la deuxième partie voilà
donc ça va être chaud ça va être chaud
ce championnat du monde pour
l'ukrainienne maria music uk et où il
fallait bien parti pour récupérer
officiellement son titre dont on sait
que de faire elle pas vraiment perdu
puisqu'elle n'a pas joué ce tournoi l'an
dernier elle avait déjà le titre avant
et elle ne fait que finalement c'était
presque un tournoi des candidats
finalement qu'on a eue l'an dernier et
c'est difficile de considérer comme un
institut qui est championne du monde
sans avoir joué lifan ou la tenante du
titre ce qu'elle fait donc cette année
voilà donc c'était la deuxième partie de
ce match holy fans mutti tchouk maria
2016 championnat du monde féminin
avantage à la chinoise pour la suite des
opérations la merci de m'avoir suivi sur
des contacts et je vous donne rendez
vous pour la troisième partie au revoir